tell me if this is right or wrong i
don't know why i keep hearing focal or
you having a record with cardi b tucked
um
no comment okay
in my opinion that means yes
[Laughter]
because if i say no if i say no i'm also
saying it's not supposed to happen
that's fair okay i see i see you it
could be it could be a yes it could be a
no but i'm gonna say no comment um i
look forward to
to reconnecting with cardi though you
know what i'm saying it's been a minute
since we we got in you know well i mean
there that's another thing rhythm and
flow season two was gonna happen and
then the pandemic happened yeah and i'm
sure you would have made an appearance
in some capacity yeah i would have for
sure showed up and be like hey you would
have been like a guest
a guest judge for an app for an episode
or something like the la episode you're
like yeah we gotta guest judge d smoke
right right i remember when i was there
you know but no um you know if they need
me when they when they're pulling up
i'll show up for them but i don't know
when and if that's gonna happen so